never have i ever waited more than three
dates to have sex
never have you waited more than three
dates wait i have i have waited more
than that i've waited a very long time
so i drank
so we have all waited more than three
dates to have sex yes regrettably
go ahead rolo what happened the mack
daddy himself how long did it take
some more jameson believe it or not
believe it or not it was not always the
red pill roll of tomassi that's okay
you shock shock everybody here uh i mean
we all i mean
i think most guys who get into sort of
like red pill manosphere kind of stuff
they have to go through like a cycle
like people always ask me like
how did you get red pilled right like
it's a verb and i'm like well
it's like you know there was a time when
i i i was very blue pill i was very red
pill i was very you know my rockstar 20s
i didn't care about
you know didn't care about anything then
that was actually a very fun memorable
time of my life and then later on and
you get involved with with other people
so it's like um one of the iron rules of
tomasi is uh iron rule number three
which is any girl that makes you wait
for sex the sex is never worth the wait
and it's not that it's not
it's not the investment side now listen
to me before you hear me because a lot
of people like take this the wrong way
is it's about desire it's about the
genuine desire not about like the oh
well i got a third date better get going
you know it's not that it's about
determining genuine desire after three
dates should be more than enough time to
figure out if this chick is into you or
if there's some sort of mitigating
factor between you getting into uh into
bed with her or into a relationship with
that you must have a lot of people that
get mad at that comment oh i'm not
saying i get mad at you but there's a
lot really hear me out hear me out for a
second that's the number one there's a
lot i just i was just shout out to this
event called model volleyball just in
south beach my friends put it on i was
just so this weekend interviewed vince
vaughn i [ __ ] love that guy i saw
that um
and i interviewed a lot of the models a
lot of the females there i'm saying how
long does it would you
i said describe your ideal man give me
the three qualities humor was up there
right obviously money attractive looks
what have you they described their ideal
man and i said how long if did you meet
this ideal man would it take for him to
get you into bed and the answers were
wildly different some girls are like
dude that night and some girls are like
no sex till marriage
you know total wide range of answers but
you're saying no more than three well
you must get a lot of hate
that's a three strikes rule but remember
it's not about it's not about oh well
you want a loose girl that's not what
that's about it's about determining
genuine desire to see if there's like a
connection that there's a chemical
reaction between you and that person so
it's like if she can't keep her hands
off of you genuine desires what i'm
talking about it's not it's not about
like oh this is a litmus test for uh
whether the girl girl's loose or she's
not or she it's the same night late
versus like you know three to three
dates later um that's not what the it's
it's about determining the interest
level and the genuine desire what does
that mean determining the gender
okay so it's is is there a chemical
reaction
between you and that person i'll give
you an example here let me give you this
story and i i think i've told this story
in a while uh working in the alcohol
industry um i've worked with on like say
martini fests and things like that for
um
uh certainly up in church street in
orlando and down deerfield beach and you
know so what i'm doing is i'm i'm
choosing these girls to come and do
these these events so i have what i i
call my my poor girls okay now this is
back in the day so p o u o u
there was one conversation that i had
with them at one point and it was like
would you ever get with a guy
and have sex with him on the same night
that you that you met him or have you
ever done that and of course they're
giggling of course i have
if you know if he was hot enough blah
blah blah but not if he was boyfriend
material
and so there was this i i would i all of
the boundaries and all of the you know
the the
you know the hot monkey sex that i want
to have with this this one guy who's the
hot guy in the foam cannon party in
cancun on spring break there's that guy
and then there's the guy who's boyfriend
material and they would make that guy
wait but they wouldn't make the
hot guy wait because there's this sense
of urgency particularly younger women
because they're that's at their their
peak potential they're at their point
what is the difference between a hot guy
that you meet and a guy that would
you would make your boyfriend maybe the
ladies child that maybe they can answer
is there a difference does he have a
point here do you agree with rolo does
is there a guy that you want to have sex
with on the night that you meet him or
is there and a difference between a guy
who's like oh i think i could really see
myself with this guy in the long term
and would you is there a difference in
timing it's really cats versus dads but
that's the okay i mean
any person that i meet i don't want to
be in the mindset of like
negotiating with myself when i can be
intimate and when i can't
i'd if i'm already thinking about that
it's not for me
um and i do even if it's just supposed
to be for fun i need somebody to treat
me like um girl for material just
because that's that shows me that i can
be free with my body with that person
and he'll respect it
you were just talking a moment ago about
uh the guy who was love bombing you
right right so that's is that the guy
that was boyfriend material or was that
the guy who was just sort of you know
fun for now kind of guy
well he
i was i was really really overwhelmed by
excitement
because he was an exciting person
very big on on social media so
i definitely went with it but i also had
in the back of my mind like there's no
way this is going to work
so i knew that from the beginning just
by his behavior
and i just kind of went along for the
ride it ended up being a little bit
painful so i learned my lesson but it's
a lesson that i was like totally happy
to learn
what was the lesson
um just because something seems fun and
exciting doesn't mean you have to do it
[Music]
you